I woke up one day and like was having
Vision issues could hardly see knocked
out my hearing which threw off my
equilibrium my balance and I couldn't
walk and I had vasculitis Ashton Kutcher
opens up about the life-threatening
illness he faced back in November 2019.
literally it was life-threatening and so
going from a life-threatening illness
then he's now back to his entirely
normal self and it really is amazing to
watch he didn't want to hide it he
wanted to be an inspiration for others
and that's just who he is and gives
props to his wife Mila Kunis for her
support we are so fortunate to have one
another Ashton appears on the premiere
episode of Paramount Plus's new health
series The checkup with Dr David agus
and recalled suffering from vasculitis a
serious and rare autoimmune disease that
attacks and inflames the blood vessels
which can lead to potential
complications such as blood clots and
organ damage there's a standard you
become accustomed to in your life like
being able to see clearly like and then
suddenly you get you can't see like you
have just like occlusion and you give
like you can't see and then like why are
you not talking about her because I
can't hear you you want to reclaim the
health that you once had the actor
previously discussed his health battle
in an August episode of running wild
with Bear Grylls telling the survivalist
he was lucky to be alive
I had this weird super rare form of
vasculitis
that I like knocked out my
vision and knocked out my hearing yeah
and knocked out like all my equilibrium
it took me like a year to like build it
all back up it came to a point where
Mila called me and said Ashton is just
you know he's not saying things that
make sense shortly I Ashton revealed all
that
they handled
gear by staying focused on the
day-to-day you kind of just power
through you go you you you deal with it
with whatever health issue comes your
way uh but you still got kids you still
got a family you still got you gotta do
you gotta live life and I think that
it's you know we are so fortunate to
have one another but as far as like
sitting there and and
incessantly talking about things no we
gotta do I will say your wife was
amazing
just curled up there by your side it was
a beautiful thing to watch she's the
best and Ashton he explained what kept
Him motivated during his recovery if I
can go from not being able to walk to
running a marathon in a three-year span
then I can sort of just let that be a
part of the past and be like I'm back
I'm good you ran a New York City
marathon several weeks ago and finished
with a time that everybody would be
envious of so obviously he's back but it
was scary as for Mila something tells us
she tuned in to watch Ashton on Dr
aegis's new show she gushed to E.T about
the doc back in 2021 I think that his
ethos as a doctor in his bedside Manner
and the way that he makes everybody feel
comfortable he's
hands down the smartest person I ever
met and he just wants people to be okay
like there's no God complex behind it
there's no ego behind it and he wants
everyone to feel safe and comfortable
[Music]
thank you